>> Sean: FOX NEWS ALERT.
RUDY GIULIANI I COMMEND BOB
MUELLER'S OFFICE FOR
CORRECTING THE FAKE BUZZFEED
STORY THAT TRUMP ENCOURAGED
CO-TON LIE.
I ASK THE PRESS TO TAKE HEED
THAT THEIR HYSTERICAL DESIRE
TO DESTROY THIS PRESIDENT
HAS GONE TOO FAR.
THEY PURSUED THIS WITH
WITHOUT CRIMINAL ANALYSIS
ALL DAY #FAKE NEWS.
WE GO NOW TO THE PRESIDENT'S
ATTORNEY JAY SEKULOW, ALSO
THE CHIEF COUNCIL FOR THE
CENTER FOR LAW AND JUSTICE.
>> HI, SEAN.
>> Sean: THIS IS HOW IT WENT
ALL DAY, JAY.
WELL, WE HAVEN'T VERIFIED IT
OURSELVES BUT, IF TRUE, AND
THIS INTOT DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA BUT, IF TRUE AND THEN
THEY GO TO IMPEACHMENT.
THIS HAS GONE ON TWO
STRAIGHT YEARS FALSE REPORT
AFTER FALSE REPORT.
CONSPIRACY THEORY AFTER
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
I THINK ONE OF THE OTHER
NETWORKS I COUNTED IN THE
COURSE OF AN HOUR 17 OR 19
TIMES THEY SAID IF THIS WAS
TRUE, IF THIS HAPPENED, IF
THESE FACTS COULD BE
VERIFIED, WHICH WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO VERIFY, THIS
WOULD BE A CRIME THAT'S LIKE
SAYING IF SOMEONE ROBBED A
BANK IT WOULD BE CRIME.
IF SOMEONE DID ROB A BANK IT
WOULD BE A CRIME.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR A
MOMENT TO REFLECT ON THIS
WAS ACTUALLY A GOOD DAY FOR
JUSTICE AND A VERY, VERY
GOOD DAY FOR THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES ALSO
IMPORTANT TO SAY AND FOCUS
ON WHAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE ACTUALLY
SAID.
SEAN, MY JOB AS THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER LEGAL
TIME IS TO ANALYZE THESE
TEAM AND TO RESPOND TO WHAT
WAS GOING ON.
THIS FRENZY WAS THAT GOING
ON THE LAST 24 HOURS.
>> LET ME START WITH WHAT HE
ACTUALLY SAID.
THIS IS FROM BOB MUELLER'S
OFFICE.
BY THE WAY THE FIRST TIME
THEY HAVE SPOKEN PUBLICLY
ABOUT A FALSE NEWS STORY.
THIS IS WHAT THEY SAID
BUZZFEED'S DESCRIPTION OF
SPECIFIC STATEMENTS TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
THAT'S ONE AND CHARACTERIZE
OF DOCUMENTS, THAT'S TWO.
AND, TESTIMONY OBTAINED BY
THIS OFFICE, REGARDING
MICHAEL COHEN'S
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY ARE
NOT ACCURATE.
SO IT'S THREE THINGS.
IT'S THE DESCRIPTION OF THE
SPECIFIC STATEMENTS TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
THE CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE THE
BASIS UPON WHICH THE MEDIA
SPECULATION STARTED.
AND THE TESTIMONY OBTAINED
BY THE OFFICE REGARDING
MICHAEL COYEN COOPERATION
WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE.
ALL OF THAT IS REPORTED IN
THE REPORT TODAY ARE NOT
CORRECT.
THIS ISN'T COMING FROM ME.
IT'S NOT COMING FROM THE
AMERICAN CENTER FOR LAW AND
JUSTICE.
IT'S NOT COMING FROM MY
4R5U678.
IT'S COMING FROM THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S BOB MUELLER'S
OFFICE.
RUDY GIULIANI IS RIGHT IN
SAYING THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND I'M GLAD
THEY DID IT WHERE DOES THAT
LEAVE US?
SO, SEAN, HERE IS WHAT I
THINK THIS IS.
THIS IS A WARNING SIGN TO
EVERYBODY THAT THE
SPECULATION, WITH NO FACTUAL
BACKUP IS DANGEROUS FOR OUR
REPUBLIC.
AND, LOOK, I HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH THIS, AS YOU
KNOW, FOR MORE THAN 24
HOURS.
ABOUT 24 HOURS.
ACTUALLY, IT STARTED LAST
NIGHT ABOUT 10:00.
SO ABOUT AN HOUR FROM NOW.
AND, THE END RESULT OF THIS
WAS THE RIGHT THING.
IT TOOK US 24 HOURS TO GET
THE RIGHT THING.
BUT, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR EVERYONE THAT'S WATCHING
TO REALIZE THAT THE
SPECULATION AND THE MEDIA
ANXIOUSNESS TO REPORT OUT OF
THE GATE HAS GOT TO STOP.
BUT THERE IS ALSO ANOTHER
MESSAGE IN ALL OF THIS.
YOU SAID THIS IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE.
PEOPLE SAY IS THERE ANY
ACTION BEING TAKEN ON THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING WRONG
DEEDS, ILLEGAL CONTACT?
WELL, LET'S LOOK AT IT.
JAMES BAKER THE GENERAL
COUNSEL OF THE FBI IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR, WHAT,
LEAKING TO THE MEDIA.
ANDREW MCCABE.
>> Sean: LET ME JUST SAY
SOMETHING.
JAY, WE JUST LEARNED THAT
THIS WEEK COMEY'S FBI, YOU
HAVE HIS DEPUTY ANDREW
MCCABE IS UNDER A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
NOW THE GENERAL COUNSEL DID.
>> FOR LEAKING.
>> THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR
LEAKING THEY ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING THAT,
SEAN AND THEY ARE LEAKING
DOCUMENTS AND TESTIMONIABLE
5U9D LEAST STATEMENTS.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE FIRED
AND UNDER INVESTIGATION.
WE HAVE GOT TO FOCUS ON
THAT.
>> Sean: FALSE REPORTING,
WHICH WE HAVE DOCUMENTED AND
I BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT IS
FOREVER BRANDED RIGHTLY SO
FAKE NEWS AS SUCH AND FOR
THEM TO EVER GET THEIR
CREDIBILITY BACK, I DON'T
THINK IT'S EVEN POSSIBLE.
LOOK WE LEARNED ABOUT BAKER.
WE KNOW ABOUT ANDREW MCCABE
AND STRZOK AND PAGE THEY
WERE EVEN ARE APPOINTED TO
MUELLER'S TEAM ALONG WITH
JEANNE WRAY WHO USED TO BE
ATTORNEY AND PIT BULL ANDREW
WEISSMANN.
HERE'S MY QUESTION, BRUCE
OHR WE LEARNED UNDER OATH
AND RELEASED IN TESTIMONY
THIS WEEK THAT HE WARNED
EVERYBODY ABOUT THE PHONY
DOSSIER.
HE WARNED THAT CLINTON PAID
FOR IT HE WARNED THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HAD A
HATRED FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE WARNED IT WASN'T VERIFIED
OR CORROBORATED.
BUT IT STILL BECAME THE BULK
OF INFORMATION.
>> YEAH, I HAVE ALWAYS ASKED
THE QUESTION OF WHAT ABOUT
TO THE EVIDENCE THAT WAS
GATHERED DURING THE COURSE
OF THE PROCEEDINGS, THE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WERE
OUTSIDE LEGAL PARAMETERS NOT
APPROPRIATE, NOWFT LEGAL.
BECAUSE IT'S ALL FROM THE
FRUIT OF THE POISONOUS TREE.
BRUCE OVER DID TELL THE
HIGHER UP AT THE FBI MY GOSH
HE WAS NUMBER FOUR.
DOSSIER WAS BIASED AND PAID
FOR BY POLITICAL OPERATIVES.
HIS WIFE WORKED FOR THE
POLITICAL OPERATIVE COMPANY
THAT PUT THE DOSSIER
TOGETHER.
THERE IS ALSO SIMULTANEOUS
WITH HIS MEA CULPA FROM
BRUCE OHR IS R. TEXT
MESSAGES THAT'S BEEN
RELEASED BETWEEN BRUCE OHR
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE THE
SO-CALLED BRITISH SPY.
THAT IS A PLEA FOR BRUCE OHR
AND CHRIS STEELE FOR STEELE
TO COME BACK TO WORK TO THE
FBI RIGHT AFTER JAMES COMEY
IS FIRED.
NOW, ASK YOURSELF THIS
QUESTION:  WHY WAS
CHRISTOPHER STEELE FIRED BY
THE FBI IN THE FIRST PLACE?
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER TO THAT ONE IS?
A LEAK TO THE MEDIA.
SO THIS IS -- LOOK, I WILL
LEGIT MACY OF THE INQUIRY
FROM THE OUTSET IS
INCREDIBLE.
IT'S THE CONSISTENCY OF
GETTING INFORMATION OUT
HERE.
AGAIN, I'M GLAD THOUGHT
OFFICE -- THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE TODAY
ISSUED THIS VERY CLEAR
THREE-PART STATEMENT AND
ANALYZE IT AND SOME OF THESE
NETWORKS TRYING TO PARS IT,
IT'S LONG TRYING TO.
WHAT'S THE CONSISTENT THEME
THROUGH THIS?
>> HE STARTED LEAKING AS
WELL?
JAMES COMEY.
HE SAID HE GAVE HIS NOTES A
WITH A NFRGS HE HAD WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO A FRIEND OF HIS TO
LEAK THE PRESS SO HE BEGINS
THE APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL WHICH LOW AND BEHOLD
HAPPENS.
THAT'S WHAT I WANTS
EVERYBODY FOCUSING ON
TONIGHT.
A CONSISTENT PATTERN OF
LEAKING U, IT'S NOT THE
F.B.I. FBI SOMEONE EXPLAIN
THIS TO ME THERE ARE EMAILS
OR TEXT MESSAGES MISS FROM
THE TIME THAT THEY WERE AT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE.
THE RESOURCE OFFICER, AT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
SAYS WELL, WE DIDN'T REALLY
CHECK THE MATERIAL.
ONE PHONE WAS LEFT AND THE
OTHER PHONE WAS RECIRCULATED
AND NO ONE CHECKED THE TEXT
MESSAGING.
SO, LOOK, AGAIN, I AM GLAD
THAT BOB MUELLER'S OFFICE
ISSUED A STATEMENT.
IT WAS CALLED FOUR.
IT WAS DUE.
IT WAS THE APPROPRIATE THING
TO DO.
BUT, THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT ARE STILL NOT
ANSWERED BY THE ACTIVITIES
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE HERE.
NOW, AGAIN, IT'S A GOOD
DAY -- GREAT DAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND GREAT DAY FOR
THE COUNTRY.
NOT SUCH A GREAT FOR THE
MEDIA.
I CALL FRIENDS OF MINE IN
THE MEDIA TODAY TO WATCH
THIS BE VERY CAREFUL HERE.
BE VERY CAREFUL.
UNVERIFIED.
WE TOLD YOU THAT --
>> -- ONE YEAH WE SAW THE
EVIDENCE THE OTHER SIDE THEY
DIDN'T.
OF COURSE THEY RELEASED THE
DOSSIER WITHOUT ANY
CORROBORATION.
HERE'S THE DANGEROUS PART
AND THE SERIOUS PART OF ALL
OF THIS.
IT'S HURTING THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS AN OBSESSION.
>> YES.
>> Sean: CONGRESS.
IF VERIFIED, IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT.
THIS HAS BEEN TWO YEARS THE
MEDIA THINKING ON ON STRUXZ
OF ERIN JUSTICE IS A REALLY
SERIOUS ISSUE WHILE IGNORE
THE GLEETION OF SUBPOENA
EMAILS U BLEACH BIT.
HAMMERS, SIM TARRED MOVED.
MANUFACTURING CRISIS.
THE MEDIA SAYS MANUFACTURED
CRISIS AGAIN AND AGAIN.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF THEY WANT
THIS TO HAPPEN SO BAD THEY
CANNOT -- THEY CANNOT GET
OVER THIS OBSESSION WHICH
REALLY IS HATE AND REALLY
HURTS THE COUNTRY.
>> WELL, LOOK, THIS IMPACTS
THE PRESIDENT, THE OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENCY AND THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
LET ME SAY SOMETHING.
IF YOU LOOKED AT THE OTHER
NETWORKS, WHICH I KNOW YOU
DON'T DO.
IN MY JOB I HAVE GOT TO LOOK
AT ALL OF IT, RIGHT?
>> Sean: I'M SORRY THAT YOU
HAVE TO DO THAT THAT'S
PUNISHMENT.
>> SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
CHALLENGES BUZZFEED
STATEMENT REGARDING THE
PRESIDENT DIRECTING SOMEONE
TO LIE.
THAT'S ALL I NEEDED TO SAY